what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so getting into Harley Quinn again
for DC Weber they've kind of touched off
and on on this so the reason being
because Harley Quinn's one of these
characters that's a mixed bag if you
love her character or you hate her
character there really aren't very many
people who are in between some are some
are just kind of like wow man I could
take her in doses I'm one of those guys
where I'm like I can I can read Harley
Quinn depending on the story not
everything that she does resonates with
me but for the most part Jimmy Palmer
yachty and Amanda Connor have done a
pretty consistent good job you know
pretty pretty good job building her
character and making her into something
unique and reason why I say this is
because we had talked about this when it
was like Harley Quinn against zombies
you know that it was this notion of
taking her character and turning the
Harley Quinn series into this kind of
like home for misfit toys so to speak in
the sense that you know I don't mean
that in a bad way I mean the ODC has
done that historically for example after
crisis on Infinite Earths we got Justice
League International and it was DC
saying hey here are the characters whose
colleagues you would normally never read
on their own instead we're just going to
throw them on a team we're going to see
what happens when we mix up these weird
personalities from these different
characters as they've been written
before and hopefully something good
comes out of it and a lot of good came
out of Justice League International it
started to drop off it's time one on his
the return of the traditional Justice
League during Grant Morrison's JLA but
the fact remains that for what it was at
the time people absolutely loved it when
Harley Quinn is much the same way she's
always been a character that in a lot of
ways was tied to the Joker and the goal
of Jimmy Paul me Ari and Amanda Connor
was to remove her from the element of
the Joker and say who's Harley Quinn
when she's her own character and the
result is I should became one of the
most popular titles in the really in the
new 52 you going into DC rebirth when it
came to DC Comics she was kind of a
standout star even right now in DC
rebirth she's one of the top-selling
titles they had so a lot of people
really really really love Harley Quinn
and the reason for this is because of
the fact that as we get into this we
basically took her with Harley Quinn
like inner classic suit and it's really
cool to see this you know the Batman the
Animated Series Harley Quinn being
introduced to DC fans everywhere for the
very first time seeing this classic
version of her the problem with this is
that she wakes up because egg foo
suddenly comes out of nowhere as she
actually throws a dagger in him
cracking the shell now what you guys who
don't know when it came to the Harley
Quinn title what Amanda Connor and Paul
Miyagi did is they basically made her
the superintendent so to speak at this
apartment complex where she basically
runs it's actually kind of maintains our
income and the reason why is because
it's usually accepted I don't think that
we've actually been given a definitive
timeframe but it's generally accepted
that the Harley Quinn line of stories as
they exist right now
take place like five years in the future
which is the reason why you see her in
New York but she's also on the Suicide
Squad right now in DC rebirths Justice
League versus Suicide Squad so if that's
the only real way we know how to
reconcile that at least us with a weekly
poll anyway myself any style you know
comic story and comic-con cape joel you
know that sea monster we've been talking
about this we've been trying to figure
out a way to understand where this takes
place and it seems like it really just
takes place five years in the future but
the fact remains here that egg foo is
one of the the occupants of this
apartment complex and egg foo is again
just basically a giant egg that's all he
is he's like as a hybrid he's like a
cyborg and of course he has little
appendages and things like that but was
Harley Quinn hitting him suddenly all
the dogs that she adopted in the
neighborhood start eating egg foo and so
for she snaps out of a dream and she
goes and talks to a guy named named
Frank Frank released Frank Frank kind of
one of those weird funny little little
things here but the idea is if Frank's
just like a restaurant owner but it's
actually kind of cool the way the Tommy
Adi and Amanda Connor do this because I
don't know about you guys but for me
sometimes like if you're running into an
issue or you have a problem or something
like that it's a lot easier to talk to
somebody that you don't know who you'll
never see again
as opposed to somebody that you do know
and reason why is because if you were to
have that conversation with them and
then you run into them somewhere the
concern of having you know that
discussion may make things a little bit
uncomfortable but for Frank Frank he's
just like a restaurant guy I mean you
know it's just Harley Quinn talking to a
random person of course the deal was she
would buy him a pizza and get him a
six-pack and he would offer his own
advice and the cool thing about this is
that it's really kind of like Amanda
Connor and Jimmy Kalyani by way of Frank
Frank giving us the idea the direction
that Harley Quinn stories are at right
now which is to say that after the
zombies after her own little escapade
she feels like her life is spiraling out
of control that she feels in a lot of
ways she's returning back to the life
that she led when she was alongside the
Joker and it's kind of interesting with
that with that situation because we
would look at that and say well if
Harley Quinn and the Joker were like the
one-two punch of Gotham City of that the
criminal underworld then her role was to
be the sidekick of the Joker how
difficult can that be
well what Tommy audio manna Connor was
focusing on was you
she wanted to be her own character and
so she was doing whatever the Joker
wanted to do and her life was basically
falling to the wayside and because of
that she felt like he was very much
spiraling out of control that's one of
the reasons why she took off why she
basically started her life anew was to
basically get things back under her
control again so Christ's advice or
Frank Frank's advice I love the
character of Frank Frank I love this guy
Frank's advice is to basically just go
and relax and chill you know go take a
vacation and so we have Harley Quinn and
we have poison ivy taking up residence
in the Bahamas or at least this little
section of the Bahamas now this is kind
of a funny situation here because Paul
Miyagi and Amanda Connor had for the
longest time toyed with the notion of
poison ivy and Harley Quinn and it
basically been confirmed that the two of
them were in a relationship and so fans
were kind of interested to see where
this went because with Harley Quinn's
character we'd seen her act alongside a
lot of other lead female characters and
mmm DC Comics it always came out pretty
well
one of the most popular team-ups really
with Harley Quinn was a Harley Catwoman
and poison ivy in Gotham City sirens a
publication that ran for onload 22 23 24
maybe was twenty six issues between 2009
and 2011 written by Paul Dini and it was
wildly popular in fact we're actually
getting a movie based on that which I'm
really excited about but you know it's
it was really this idea that Harley
Quinn and poison ivy always had
something special and so to sort of see
that confirmed you know and by Amanda
Connor and Jimmy Paul miyagi and their
run up to this point to see the two of
them forming their own relationship was
always a really fun and an interesting
dynamic that really changed the Harley
Quinn landscapes because it grounded her
but the other half of this is that we're
actually encountering a guy named cyborg
now cyborg Minh was basically the one
that gave them this place to stay you
know this condo and the place called the
colony but five boardman was introduced
in Harley Quinn number four I think I
want to say it was either DC Weaver's of
the new 52 but cyborg 1 was essentially
a guy who was really like an assassin at
one point in time he was like a spy he
ended up having a bunch of as you know
his limbs blown off and so on and so
forth but the actions of Harley Quinn as
she pertained to him was basically
finishing a contract - cyborg when
himself never got a chance to finish but
because she came out on top because of
her efforts to assist cyborg man he's
more or less become a strong friend of
hers and so because of that he's like
hey look if you guys want to take up
residence you guys want to relax I can
give you a place to do that the problem
with this is that it's basically a nude
colony now in a normal circumstances it
wouldn't be bad - this nude colony it's
just that it's a nude colony filled with
old people and so it's
it's an issue because there's a bunch of
old naked people running around but
again the cool thing about this is this
focus is really really heavily on Harley
Quinn and in poison ivy but it's also
Jimmy pollyali and Amanda Connor saying
the Joker is going to come back the
Joker is coming back here and the reason
why this happened is because of the fact
that the two of them have a conversation
that basically been stalled there was
one point where Harley Quinn and in
poison ivy we're having a discussion you
know about a package that Harley Quinn
had found or something that was there
was supposed to be delivered to her but
the conversation was cut short and when
so poison ivy basically asked you know
what was what was it you were going to
say give me the whole the whole spiel
here Harley Quinn says that she was
basically sent to stop people who were
who were stealing mail but when she went
through or at least when she when she
stopped those guys she found an envelope
that had been sent to her from Arkham
Asylum and when she opened it up it was
one of her evaluation sheets now again
this is Paul Miyagi and Amanda Connor
kind of harkening back to the early days
of Harley Quinn and the funny thing
about Harley's time when she first
became the therapist and Arkham Asylum
is that different people have been in
different ways and they've depicted her
different ways there were some writers
who depicted her as basically being a
sociopath
ever since she was young where it was
presumed that she had been abused by her
by her father that she was someone who
basically used people for her own ends
that she slept her way through at school
so that she could get a degree that she
needed that she manipulated and tricked
people when she was at Arkham Asylum its
rise through the ranks and that her
having such a dubious set of motivations
in terms of how she dealt with people
ultimately led her to being attracted to
the Joker there were other people who
depicted Harley Quinn as somebody who
was just caught up in the charismatic
nature of the Joker and that seems to be
the direction that homey Adi and Amanda
Connor are going here that Harley Quinn
when she initially shows up is very
professional here you know her first
encounter with the Joker is very
professional she's basically just asking
standard question now of course the
Joker's doing what the Joker does this
is why we love the Joker because you
never know what's going to happen you
know the Joker is like a box of
chocolates
don't probably kill you with Joker toxin
I would never accept a box of chocolates
from the Joker I would never eat the
hook but but the Joker is kind of a
mixed bag in a sense that you know for
him it could go any direction I mean
that's one of the reasons why is
character so popular is because Scott
Snyder is like here's the really dark to
really you know really screwed up
sadistic joke I mean we idle about you
I love that version of the Joker but at
the same time we get seen Eagleheart
Joker who's crazy as hell and wants to
copyright fish we can all be seven
versions of the Joker the way he's
changed over the years and each version
adds something new and unique to the
story but this version of the Joker is
very manipulative now in terms of what
led him to manipulate Harlequin is not
really explained here instead it's
really just this notion if the Joker is
basically taken to her you know in the
sense of the Joker tries to turn the
tables on her tries to mess with her
head but this is how the Joker works
because it's not like he hits you over
the head with a sledgehammer and
suddenly you're under his control
it's subtle manipulations that take
place over time it's a war of
psychological attrition it just goes on
and on and on and on until eventually
you just can't take anymore and
eventually you just give in and that
really seemed to be what happened with
Harley Quinn that seemed to be the
direction that Jimmy Palmer Otte and
Amanda Connor were taking what it
basically said throughout all her
meetings so Joker basically kept saying
hey look you're your shackling yourself
you're constraining yourself to the
realm of sanity you got to break free
you got to get out there you got to be
the person you were meant to be and
while on the surface with this initial
encounter Poliquin dismisses it and just
considers it the ravings of a madman as
time progresses it begins to take a toll
and she begins to believe that the
Joker's right and eventually she swept
up in his madness and so you know while
she's going through this discussion with
with poison ivy they're all suddenly met
by the sea by the arrival of old people
all the old people just about to start
skinny-dipping in the pool and start
playing volleyball now the crazy thing
about this and this is one of reasons
why I like this so much is because you
know even though it is a bunch of naked
old people in a pool which is a little
weird it looks like some of the most fun
you could ever have playing volleyball
in the pool but you know Harley Quinn
just kind of enjoying the moment she's
celebrating the moment you know she's
relaxing it really is legitimately
a chance for her to wind down it has the
experience of the shoes Hannah she's
been ridden it's really what she needed
the problem with this is that the
following week two winter vacations up
and it's time to go poison ivy is always
a little you know is a little bit
distant here and the reason why is
because the idea was at Harley Quinn and
poison ivy we're supposed to move in
together and of course we get the spiel
we get the It's Not You It's Me speech
and that's really what happens here you
know Harley Quinn says hey are you
considering you know the idea of us
moving in together have you thought
about it employees and Ivy says you know
in
anytime there's a conversation like this
in a perfect world I would well then you
know things are going to start going
downhill from there because it's
basically it's the Green Mile of
breakups is ernamaria
majored with the green mile of breakups
it's setting on that path and the end is
nigh and so you know Harley Quinn takes
it with grace
you know she basically says okay look
you know I guess that's the way it is
but for her this is devastating and the
reason why is so devastating for Harley
Quinn is because you got to keep in mind
depending again on how people depicted
her own story the Joker was really the
first time that she found like tried and
true acceptance the problem with this
that the Joker was crazy as hell and so
he was very very abusive and she even
addressed this and a lot of stories
where she said the Joker would make her
do things you know things with him that
she wasn't really comfortable with he
would make her commit crimes you know
she lived a life that she wasn't really
comfortable with and getting away from
that and finding love with poison ivy
was great because it made her feel like
she could be a normal person made it
feel like she could have a regular life
or at least a life as regular as Harley
Quinn can have but with poison ivy
basically breaking up with her that's
not the case anymore that she's kind of
left you know with the friends that she
has which of course she celebrates but a
lot of her life is basically gone but
what this does is this sets the stage
for the Joker to make his return for the
Joker to show up and he's going to show
up while she's in a very emotional place
while she's in a very emotional state
well I will say things can go one of two
ways and I will let you guys debate
freely on what direction you guys think
you guys think things will go in but if
you're new here to come and explain make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the rapport if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you guys
drop a like and yeah I'll catch you all
in it please
[Music]